okay next game with a slick image play
on play c4 for change ok so I'm going
for Kings Indian set up let's play the
form ok yeah I don't know the Benoni
stuff with you five really well so
interesting ok let's um let's try a
sideline here this is a somewhat
annoying sideline for black the problem
is some you're both see pawns are
somewhat weak but white is just a bit
bit quicker in releasing the bishop ok
is going for complete symmetry here
let's see do I have some some
possibilities maybe to capture on c6 and
try to put pressure on c5 not sure
they take care night a4e has got Knight
b6 that this is annoying you also might
play Knight d4
I lied before so what sorts of plan here
if I take and play Bishop d2 first cover
everything and then try to apply
pressure okay let's try this it's
interesting i think not sure but it's
really good for him but ok this is meant
to protect the night to to have be three
if he for instance um ok is going for
the direct exchange you can need to
exchange of course c4 was hanging also
so no see one get out of the sea file
and now the idea would be just yeah okay
I cannot castle but I'm I don't need to
I'm idea would be to apply pressure here
with night a form let's check you can
just this is just another tech I
playbook g1 ok let's attack this pawn
he plays Bishop g4 now also to cover it
I have fun yeah i also have III but this
would weaken the white squares really am
enormously I don't want that so if he
plays Bishop g4 I might just play Bishop
e3 and ya know interesting now should be
three the only issue could be that he
might I might enter with the rook here
somehow but ok let's say let's say he
captures now only three ft eggs and then
maybe let's say rook somewhere work g6
to double the rooks then
not sure look the only escape route t8
okay choose choose this way
okay let's let's grab this of course you
can now also take on c5 to get opposite
colored bishops I'm stupid you can just
capture that oh god oh god this is
terrible from a great position to 20 I
completely overlook this Wow okay now we
just got the bishop pair I have got
nothing
what a terrible overside gotta cut okay
at least a 70 saying
you
yeah its stone it's still on that
position the lighter sir is just stupid
piece yeah
try to get the King to e3 well mm-hmm
it's a stupid piece but only with rocks
on from maybe somehow get rid of the
rooks then it's um it's okay again
well at least that cut got the King on a
somewhat active position now that should
be okay she'll be okay I've got the open
fun and maybe then maybe this is okay at
least I'm not considerably worse or
something storm to mr. take me to wasn't
just terrible check okay time morning
interesting interesting idea with ship
g-form didn't see that
whoa this is very sorry and convenient
check
oh how much worse now also time
check
check check h4 mate check check check
black or if it's on time well completely
lost to thread them all in all a rather
bad game I think yeah not sure after
this one maybe I'm I'm okay again with
some counter play yeah this should be
okay got the good rug on a 7 and it's
got somewhat weird King position but of
course I completely overlooked that you
can take on be too it was just bull
awful awful why not sure if it's a great
position but I cannot allow you to take
on b2 it's just just bad
yeah of course III is also an idea still
but looking at it now I'm not maybe
maybe I have a completely different idea
here maybe Bishop c2 c3 and then III
yeah well what I'd like to do is here to
exchange them the bishops d 2 ND form
and prevent him to to enter with through
the rook on d2 or something then c5 is
just just gone and it's a it's a great
position because he still has got the
weak points left and have just got an
extra porn but of course he's got the
activity so i need to be very cautious
that he doesn't get too much active
claim and not sure maybe bishops who is
also an idea we can of course still play
a rook t6 or something III captures
night captures had very weak on the on
the other one on the light squares yeah
difficult yeah it should be it should be
okay prob like actually i think is
active enough am I don't have I like no
maybe two moves or something to to get
this all kind consolidated bishop is
also of course somewhat annoying on h3y
a difficult difficult position ok next
one